-Guys, we are just one week away
from Halloween.
That's right. Millions of
Americans are buying candy
for trick-or-treaters,
which they will rebuy
in six days after they
polish it off themselves.
That's right. Halloween
is on a weekday this year.
Parents are like, "You mean,
I get to work a full day
and walk around for hou
in the cold darkness?
Wow. Awesome."
I love Halloween.
There's so many fun costumes
like, sexy nurse, sexy cop
sexy indicted Trump staffer.
You know, a fun costume.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But if you're still lookin
for a costume, look no further
This year,
you can actually dress up
as a sexy sold-out
Popeyes chicken sandwich.
Take a look. This is real.
There you go. Yeah.
Most people
called it ridiculous
while the President called
the Statue of Liberty and said
"You've been replaced."
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to some news here.
Just when it seemed like
things in Washington,
couldn't get any crazier, chec
out what happened earlier today.
-We start with a bizarre turn on
Capitol Hill
when as many as two dozen
House Republicans,
upset over the
impeachment inquiry,
stormed a secure hearing room.
-Yeah, Republicans stormed
a closed-door meeting
to protest
the impeachment inquiry.
Even crazier, they used
Mike Pence as a battering ram.
"Ooh! Ooh!"
-"Mother. Mother."
-"Mother! Mother! Mother!
Ooh, ooh!"
The Republicans actually stormed
the room as a Pentagon employe
was moments away from
testifying about Ukraine.
'Cause nothing says
completely innocent
like storming the room
of someone about to testify.
"Don't let him talk!
Don't let him talk!
Get in there, quick.
Get in there!
Don't let him talk."
[ Muffled shouting ]
It really turned into an
ugly scene among Republicans
I haven't seen that many
angry white guys
since NBC canceled "Frasier.
Things are pretty chaotic
in Washington.
I read that a lot of reporters
think this has been
one of the worst weeks of
Trump's entire presidency,
which is really impressive whe
you realize it's only Wednesday.
[ Laughter ]
Yesterday was
really damaging to Trump
after a U.S. diplomat,
Bill Taylor, told Congress
that Trump withheld military
funding from Ukraine
unless they agreed
to investigate
his political rivals.
I'm not saying Trump is nervous,
but when he saw the testimony,
he was like...
-[ Screaming ]
[ Laughter ]
Some 2020 news this week.
There have been a lot of reports
about how more Democratic
candidates are thinking abou
jumping into
the presidential race.
It's not clear who exactly is --
[ Woman laughing evilly ]
H--
Hillary Clinton, is that you
[ Laughter ]
-That's right, Jimmy. It's me!
And just like Mitt Romney'
secret Twitter,
I'm always lurking.
[ Laughing evilly ]
-I'm sorry. Where exactly
are you right now?
-I'm ever present, Jimmy.
Always around you,
forever at end.
-Yeah, but, really,
where are you?
-Well, I'm in
an air duct, Jimmy.
[ Thud ]
Oh! Gosh.
-All right, well,
can we have somebody help
Hillary Clinton
out of the air duct?
-See you in New Hampshire!
[ Laughs evilly ]
-Oh, my God. I hope you're okay.
Hillary Clinton
in an air duct, everyone.
I think she's up in that one
[ Cheers and applause ]
Some business news.
I saw that Tiffany's
just released an advent calendar
that costs $112,000.
Yeah.
Exactly like Jesus intended.
-Aww.
-Anyway, here it is.
This is the real thing.
Yeah. It's four feet tall.
According to Tiffany's,
behind the first three doors
are everyday objects
like a cup, a clothes pin,
and a harmonica.
[ Laughter ]
If the first three gifts
are a cup, a clothes pin,
and a harmonica,
the fourth better be fille
with $111,000.
That's all I'm saying...
[ Cheers and applause ]
If I'm gonna buy that...
-Yeah.
[ Applause ]
-Well, guys, Pizza Hut
is testing
environmentally friendly boxes
that you can actually compost.
It wasn't that hard.
The box is made out of pizza
from Papa John's.
-Oh.
Ha ha!
-I know. It's good cardboard
It's good cardboard.
Speaking of pizza,
after 23 years,
the Sbarro pizza in Times Square
is closing its doors for goo
this week.
[ Audience awws ]
I think every New Yorker i
feeling a little down about it
so I wanted to take a moment t
pay tribute to our old friend.
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ Standin' on the corner
by the Port Authority ♪♪
♪♪ And I just heard the ne
that you're gonna leave ♪♪
♪♪ Wish you weren't going,
but I guess you must ♪♪
♪♪ Every slice of life
always leaves the crust ♪♪
♪♪ Leaving us alone,
and I hate to sound needy
♪♪ But I'm missing your calzon
and your baked ziti ♪♪
♪♪ Can't believe it's over
after all these years ♪♪
♪♪ Gonna need a cup for wate
and a cup for my tears ♪♪
♪♪ 'Cause I would climb
Mount Kilimanjaro ♪♪
♪♪ To get you back,
Times Square Sbarro ♪♪
♪♪ A 12-inch pie
with a side of sorrow ♪♪
♪♪ Come back soon,
Times Square Sbarro ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪ Here today, gone tomorrow
♪♪ I want you back,
Times Square Sbarro ♪♪
♪♪ Here today, gone tomorrow
♪♪ I want you back,
Times Square Sbarro ♪♪
♪♪ Here today, gone tomorrow
♪♪ I want you back,
Times Square Sbarro ♪♪
♪♪ Here today, gone tomorrow
♪♪ Want you back,
Times Square Sbarro ♪♪
♪♪ Here today, gone tomorrow
♪♪ I want you back,
Times Square Sbarro ♪♪
♪♪ Here today, gone tomorrow
♪♪ I want you back,
Times Square Sbarro ♪♪
♪♪ Here today, gone tomorrow
♪♪ I want you back,
Times Square Sbarro ♪♪
♪♪ Here today, gone tomorrow
♪♪ I want you back,
Times Square Sbarro ♪♪
♪♪ Here today, gone tomorrow
♪♪ I want you back,
Times Square Sbarro ♪♪
♪♪ Here today, gone tomorrow
♪♪ I want you back,
Times Square Sbarro ♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪